تبث الجزيره اليوم الجمعه فيلم الهند من
اشعل الفتيل ضمن تحقيقات برنامج المسافه
صفراء حصل فريق البرنامج على شهادات
ووثائق تعرض للمره الاولى عن نفوذ
الجماعات الهندوسيه المتطرفه في الهند كما
تمكن فريق البرنامج الذي تقدمه الزميله
سلام هنداوي من الوصول الى ولايتي اسهام
شرقيه الهند ومندبراج في الغرب لاتين
تشهدان اعمال عنف واضطهاد متصاعده ضد
الاقليات المسلمه وهذه هي المره الاولى
التي يتمكن فيها فريق صحفي عربي من الوصول
الى تلك المناطق كما وثق فريق البرنامج
العديد من الشهادات باشخاص احتجزوا في
معسكرات الاعتقال بحجه انهم مهاجرون غير
شرعيين
المسافه صفر الهند من اشعل الفتيل يبث
اليوم الجمعه الثاني من يونيو حزيران ساعه
10:05 مساء بتوقيت مكه المكرمه